merry christmas chief mind if i come in
sometimes i have the urge to hurt people
you're dark passenger
merry christmas kiddo see you around
hey guys pete here i've got another
dexter new blood video for you today a
preview of the penultimate episode 9
that's coming up in a few days we're
almost at the end things are starting to
take shape so i'll be talking about the
promo teaser i'll break that down we'll
look at the episode description and some
interesting promo photos that are out
there and then we'll get into theories
about how things might go in the final
two episodes if any of that sounds like
spoilers to you then this is both your
warning and chance to leave and with
that out of the way let's get into it
the title of new blood season 1 episode
9 is the family business and the episode
description reads dexter and harrison
find themselves closer than ever over
christmas break what kind of gifts will
this father and son give to one another
but this brings this father and son into
the crosshairs of a very violent and
scary serial killer angela starts to
wonder if iron lake is not the cozy and
safe place she always thought it was the
teaser trailer opens with dexter and
harrison together in the cabin in front
of the fireplace dex says when your
grandfather found out what i was he gave
me the code that seems to be connected
to this idea of the family business and
at least one of the gifts that they'll
give each other there's a shot of angela
listening to molly's podcast about the
bay harbor butcher we hear her say i'm
going to challenge everything you think
you know about who he was and by the end
of the last episode angela was getting
closer to thinking that it might be
dexter this will probably be fuel for
the fire and i guess we should keep in
mind that dexter listened to that same
episode if there is something that might
give her a revelation there he would
know about it too while molly is talking
we see what i'm presuming is a flashback
to a mr wiggles playland or at least
that's what it says on the pamphlet we
see dexter pick up and it looks like it
says greatest show in florida there was
a lot of talk about this place before
the season came out because there were
some set photos that were created in
massachusetts where they shot the rest
of new blood and because it was a
miami-looking location that led to
speculation that dexter might be going
back there before the season ended given
where the story is and that dexter is
telling harrison about his past all
signs point to this being a story about
a kill we never saw during the original
series we've never seen this clown
character or anything related to dexter
chasing him down of course they didn't
do much to de-age michael c hall but to
me he looks more like florida decks
rather than iron lake decks and i'm
solidly in the flashback camp it looks
like he's stalking a professional clown
who they show making a balloon animal
and giving it to a young child from
there the teaser cuts the dexter in a
christmas sweater at angela's place he
looks pretty happy at first but things
take a turn at this holiday party when
curt shows up at the front door saying
merry christmas chief mind if i come in
once again dexter's killing has brought
the people he's closest to into a
situation where they're on a killer's
radar even if they have no idea about
what's going on and now that things are
out in the open there's a cat and mouse
game going on here which is a really
nice setup for some awkward interactions
his arrival is followed by some quick
shots of kurt cleaning and loading his
rifle and one that possibly gives us an
idea of where he disappeared to at the
end of the last episode he's on a ladder
anyway we'll see a little bit more of
this later with dexter and harrison and
this is all probably related to some of
the promo photos that were released for
episode 9. and one of those we see
dexter and harrison in what can only be
described as probably underground
considering the exhaust fans that are in
the background and it looks like the
wall behind them is from a shipping
container
the other one has angela with a
flashlight with her gun drawn in the
same place looking around in episode 8
when kurt was talking to elric on the
phone he was in a room with these same
walls and of course shipping containers
have played a recurring role in the
series starting with dexter watching his
own mother get killed in one where harry
eventually found him and then much later
in the series laguerta met her and in a
shipping container as well this makes it
all look really probable that kurt has a
sort of underground bunker on the same
property as the cabin and we'll come
back around to that in a minute we hear
dexter say sometimes i have the urge to
hurt people with more shots of him
preparing for the mr wiggles kill we see
that he's discovered some polaroids of
kids and hear harrison say you're dark
passenger as we see him sneak up on the
clown so there's no doubt that he will
be explaining to him the code and the
idea of a dark passenger i guess the
question is where do they go from there
next we see a shot of dexter going down
a ladder at night with harrison looking
on and following behind him it looks
like harrison shakes his head no or he
doesn't want to go down or something's
going on but it's hard to say exactly
what's happening with that in the quick
flash that we see there's one more shot
of harrison standing next to audrey
who's giving him a look and kurt says
merry christmas kiddos see you around as
he gives him a wink and shoots him with
a finger gun and the trailer ends there
things are set up in a pretty fantastic
way here where just about anything could
happen in the last two episodes some
things feel fairly inevitable like
angela putting the pieces together on
dexter being the bay harbour butcher
kurt and dexter both prioritizing
killing each other and then the promo
stuff confirms that he will at least be
introducing harrison to the code his
idea of having a dark passenger and that
they'll be united in learning more about
what's going on with kurt florida and a
mr wiggles kill look like a fun blast of
nostalgia for the character and his
origins and will probably contain a
teaching moment to pass on but i don't
expect much more there beyond a sunny
reminder of what the original series
looked like past that it's hard to pin
down how the list of problems dexter is
facing will be dealt with the difference
between angela knowing he was the bay
harbour butcher and actually being able
to prove that is huge it would be fairly
unrealistic for her to be able to
actually make a case that would stick
and that he would be worried about
there's a lot of complicated factors
that would work against that which we
saw laguerta run into whenever she was
trying to do the same thing it seems
more likely that that knowledge would
lead her to solving the cases that he
was involved with in iron lake and i
guess either way the big question is
what would she do about it if she knew
for sure that he did kill people up
until now there hasn't been much to say
that she wouldn't pursue bringing him to
justice but there's a popular theory out
there that she might see that kurt is
getting away with killing iris and these
other missing young women and that might
sway her to look the other way if a
situation arose where he could take kurt
out delivering his brand to justice she
might be able to be all right with that
while i'm bringing up popular theories
the one i probably saw the most this
week in the comments was that kurt has
already killed molly as evidenced by him
being in that room when he was talking
to elric and her not being involved in
the last episode this is possible i
suppose but to me it seems like a pretty
uneventful ending for the character the
only thing it would accomplish beyond
the initial reveal would be that it
would be a victim everyone in the
current timeline knows it might be a
slight positive for dexter and a slight
blow for angela but not much else they
do need to discover something at kurt's
underground compound but i imagine
that's where the embalming and wanting
the faces to be intact comes into play
obviously he's doing something that
involves preserving trophies of some
sort plus it hasn't been a long time
since he shot chloe and they could just
as easily come across her body as a
fresh kill if they needed evidence of
that
as far as angela being a threat unless
you do think this show is heading
towards dexter being caught in the end
then she would have to be taken out of
the picture in the past the show has
dealt with situations like this by
having a different character swoop in
and take care of it four decks
inadvertently the biggest example is
lila killing dokes and you can just
continue on from there and you can
really start going around in circles
here kurt could take care of it for him
killing her for revenge or to end any
further investigation he could do it for
self-preservation if she discovers his
underground secret some people like the
idea of harrison doing it and the weird
spot that that would put dexter in i
appreciate the sentiment that you want
to protect your old man but not sure how
i feel about you killing this woman the
other thing this show did in the past
was have dexter so focused on this
situation that he's created by killing
matt who turned out to be the son of a
serial killer that's now after him is
that he's able to win out in that
situation but some innocent people
around him paid the ultimate price
there's a lot riding on what happens in
this upcoming episode as far as how the
series will probably end i'm still
looking for something conclusive
something that'll wrap the story of the
character up in a way that the original
series never was able to do i think the
ending of the last episode was certainly
a step in that direction the
conversation with harrison finally
telling him the truth opens the door to
that emotional ending for him now he has
someone that can see him as he is and
still accept him someone that he feels
something for where he wants to protect
them and then the question becomes can
he do that in a lot of ways at this
point harrison is like a better version
of hannah he has as real of a connection
as he can have with someone with him
similar to what he had with deb and as
he said in the closing moments of
episode 8 maybe that is what he's always
wanted he also has a direct role in
harrison becoming what he is there's
responsibility there and a chance to do
what he wasn't able to do for rita or
deb when i think about it like that i
get pretty excited about this setup and
instead of continuing to go around in
circles i think this is a pretty good
place to leave things let me know in the
comments where you're landing what you
think feels right let me know what you
thought about this teaser and what
you're hoping to see in episode 9. we're
almost there we're almost at the finale
so let me hear your thoughts please like
this video if you enjoyed it please
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already and thanks for watching i'll
talk to you soon